[Music]
hi everyone
my name is teresa anders and i'm a
postdoctoral research fellow
at the herte school in berlin and today
i will talk to you about how to conduct
peer review in data science classes
using the gh class package
so why does peer review matter well it's
a great active learning tool for
students
and in particular for instructors and
really large data science classes
peer review enables them to provide
their students with
meaningful substantive feedback beyond
what might be possible
with kind of standard automated code
review tools
the gh class package now offers software
solutions to do this in r and this is
work that i did during my internship
with our studio
this past summer together with minajet
and kaio and dell and colin rondell
and so in a nutshell gh class is a
package that allows you to manage a
class that is run as a github
organization
via our commands interfacing with the
github api
and as a new feature we now added the
ability to also conduct peer review
with this structure so what are some of
the
key features that gh class allows you to
do well
first and foremost a gh class will allow
you to
automate the process of distributing and
subsequently collecting all the reviews
on github repositories
the package will allow you to create a
randomized review roster for your class
and you can also
assign more than one reviewer to an
assignment
the package allows you to automatically
collect the scores that students gave to
each other
you as the instructor can determine
whether you want the review to be single
or double blind
and last but certainly not least this
works for a number
of different assignments so this could
work for a very small
coding homework or even an entire final
project
okay so let me briefly demo for you the
four main steps that you need to know in
order to do this with
gh class so suppose we have three
students in our class
and they submitted their homework one
homework via github repositories
we can initiate the peer review process
by
creating so-called review repositories
for each of these students and the peer
init function
will automatic automatically do this for
you
the second step is to actually assign
the review
and so in my little graphic on my slides
i'm going to be focusing on the example
of bruno
as the assignment author in red and anya
as the randomly assigned reviewer for
this assignment in blue
so what peer assign does it takes
bruno's assignment makes a copy of it
and stores it in a separate folder on
anya's review repository
and this folder is anonymized so anya
doesn't know whose assignment she's
reviewing
and what peersign also does is it adds a
our markdown feedback form to this
repository
that we're going to ask anya to fill out
okay
so here we're going to do a little bit
of time traveling here
because this is the part in the in the
review process
where our students would actually
conduct the review
and so what our students are going to do
is they're going to edit the original
assignment for
the original assignment of the authors
and also fill out
the review form that we asked them to do
once this process is done you as the
instructor can now collect the scores
that these students gave to each other
and so the peer score review form will
essentially
extract the scores from the our markdown
file of the reviewers and store the
information
in either data frame or a csv file
all right we're already at step four so
the last step in this review process is
to take all the review files
from the reviewers and move it all back
to the authors
and so this is what peer return will do
for you so it will essentially
clone the author one folder from anya's
review repository
and make a copy of it on bruno's
original assignment repository
and so now bruno could go and actually
take a look at the feedback
that he got what does this look like
from the student's perspective
well peer return will also automatically
open an issue
on bruno's github repository that gives
him some instructions of what to do and
also has links to all the
great feedback that anya gave him and so
for example
if he was to click on this
assignment.rmd file
what happens is he would automatically
be seeing a github diff between his
original assignment
and then all the feedback that anya gave
him
all right there you go you learned how
to conduct peer review
with the gh class package and we have a
package downside available if you want
to know more where we have a ton of
really great vignettes step-by-step
guides and also instructions that you
can pass on to your students
thank you very much
you